do i want to see the sequel to a
christmas story starring
peter billingsley
as a grown-up version of himself maybe
it's set in the 60s
chris without checking your phone can
you name all of the christmas films you
can think of oh wow well there's a lot
there's so many that i love it's a
wonderful life
a christmas story
bad santa
uh
god they're i mean the i don't know if
you consider the grinch still christmas
it's not a christmas movie per se
but i always associate that with
christmas along with the peanuts
christmas special
i mean
oh god there's a bunch
those are just like off the top of my
head my personal favorites the ones that
i make sure to watch every year
and then there's ones that people would
argue aren't necessarily christmas
movies like die hard but i would put
that in that category just because i
love the whole uh i think it's become an
ugly christmas sweater that says ho ho
ho now i have a gun
i've seen people wear that costume
so you would consider die hard a
christmas movie for me it is for me die
hard is a christmas movie
yeah
what needs to happen in a christmas film
does christmas need to be saved
uh
yeah it's
i wonder if you could even make an
earnest christmas movie now
that isn't relegated to the hallmark
channel and by that i mean a wide
release
christmas movie
that that goes to theaters
that would appeal to people who don't
care about christmas it's just a
heartwarming movie that takes place over
the holidays i think that the thing that
needs to to happen in a christmas movie
one it's gotta take place during
christmas
which batman returns
by tim burton does it takes place during
christmas
um
it also somehow the message of christmas
has to be
in there
woven in some way
a realization a love of fellow your
fellow man
and and i think that has to be a big
part of it and lessons have to be
learned right i think that's part of
christmas is this for me there's a
feeling
that exists around christmas that is
palpable
and it usually starts around
you know
christmas eve night that you could just
feel and christmas is the next day and
it's sort of a
um
it's it's sort of a reconfirmation
of
your relationships
of people close to you and your family
or your significant other
uh and and a way to reach out to family
and friends and
you know
say hey i care about you so that has to
be a big a big part of it even if it's
woven in in the most
simple way
yes i know that it's a wonderful life is
it's dated but i feel like
what's sad to me is that
certain people would think that the
message of
it's a wonderful life is dated
that is where i have concerns because
i feel
that
in particular this comes with acts of
heroism whether it is in an actual
superhero movie or acts of
self-sacrifice or acts of
uh kindness towards a fellow human for
no reason whatsoever
whatsoever other than to do that and i
feel like that as a value has been lost
and i notice it in modern
films and television i feel like
that kindness towards your fellow
person
human
american
you know
neighbor it's it's not as present as it
used to be
unfortunately
um
[Music]
although i will say if you spent some
time on social media and you get up and
walk outside your house and normally
that that feeling isn't present but but
christmas is is uh first of all i love
those christmas movies
you know but the peanuts christmas
special would never be made today
in specifically because of the quotes
from the bible
and there was even controversy
at the time about like is this gonna be
a religious special
and
it was and now it's it's something that
has survived till today but
i think it'd be incredibly difficult
outside of a small release
religious
uh you know show film showing at
churches and whatnot or something for
the hallmark hallmark channel you
wouldn't see those kinds of religious
ideals even if it was simply the ideas
without the
bible verses
um i don't think you would see that
and it's
you know it's again it's another
fracturing of our audience right like
there's a huge audience
that would love to see a movie about
christmas even if it's only peripherally
about christmas
right
but
yeah yeah i think it is is
uh
those values those rituals are
[Music]
they're eroding and they're not as
popular on a mass scale as they used to
be
i i'm just saying what i have observed
but try to get a christmas special with
religious themes
that doesn't
on a mainstream level it'll never happen
not something made by a major
corporation is not going to do it it's
going to be relocated to a
you know what they call a vertical which
is a small audience
so there you are
when would you typically play a
christmas movie
well
christmas is my second favorite holiday
my first my favorite holiday is
halloween
the decorations go up in late september
it's a month-long
celebration
it's horror movies for the entire month
and so i love halloween uh you know
christmas i sort of like once i've
once i'm into the turkey around
thanksgiving uh then the the christmas
movies go into rotation
you know and then it's like the the ones
like um
which actually still has some heartfelt
messages bad santa you would not think
this
and you will never look at a
pickle the same way
but bad santa kind of
uh is also one of my one of my
christmas holiday favorites
if you were to write a christmas film
would you be the protagonist would you
see yourself in the protagonist
well
if i wrote a christmas movie i would not
be the protagonist of that movie i would
but i'd like to see if hollywood could
make a
you know
a new
a new
christmas movie you know to me one of my
all-time favorites is a christmas story
now could you make that movie today
could you make a movie where a kid
little ralphie
just wants
a gun for christmas
you know today's climate
it's a little different
you know
uh i i would love to see and i've heard
rumors that peter billingsley is going
to do an update of a christmas story
i'd love to see a sequel to that movie
with his character all grown up
you know maybe he wants a different type
of gun for christmas who knows
uh but you know
that movie is not just about
christmas it's also a reflection of this
of that this bygone era
um and i i just wonder if hollywood is
capable of making a movie about
christmas i feel
and this is not so much a reflection of
the industry i think audiences would
want it
i think that there's so much cynicism
in the entertainment world and christmas
is about loving your fellow loving your
neighbor
and and unity
that i wonder if hollywood is even
capable of making that type of film i
really wonder that so look do i want to
see the sequel to a christmas story
starring peter billingsley
as a grown-up version of himself maybe
it's set in the 60s i would love to see
that
uh is that going to happen i don't know
is it going to happen to a satisfying
degree we'll see
maybe he wants a glue gun maybe he's a
crafter i
yeah well we'll see but you know i don't
need several glue guns oh good okay so
so someone who makes props and sets and
things but not everybody celebrates
christmas that's true so so it does
alienate
many people
right
different you know whatever and in
whatever it might just be non-religious
maybe they don't believe in
consumerism and things like that there
could be a whole anti-corporate angle to
it
yeah i mean black friday yeah i mean
there have been yeah there have been
movies that have explored the over
commercialization of christmas
that's fine i think that's part of it i
think that's a valid critique
of the holiday
and having said that i love the
decorations i love the excuse to get
together
with
friends and family i love the idea of
we're going to take stock and inventory
of the last year and commit to being say
a better person in the new year maybe
there have been lessons learned
and
it's that that holiday period where we
can kind of take a step back and assess
you know
what have you what have we accomplished
what are we capable of doing how can we
do better
and and how can we contribute to a
better world i think that that
that
idea that message defies the holiday
forget the holiday forget the
commercialization that idea of
self-reflection
that i think is just important
for anybody you know no matter whether
you like celebrate the holiday or like
it or hate it it doesn't matter that
idea is something i think that we need
to do on an annual basis